zurück bei bild live an diesem
nikolaustag corona deutschland ist tief
gespalten und die korona lager die
radikalisieren sich immer stärker am
wochenende fackel aufmarsch vor dem haus
der sächsischen gesundheitsministerin
peter kloeppel ein protest sagen diese
leute die dort aufmarschiert sind es ist
aber mehr es ist eine drohung politiker
die bedroht werden corona deutschland
das teilweise nicht mehr diskutiert
sondern eskaliert aufmarschiert hierbei
bild sagen deshalb ganz vehement
deutschland muss zusammenhalten
aber man hat das gefühl deutschland
driftet auseinander corona greift
irgendwie nicht nur unseren körper an
sondern auch unsere gesellschaft genau
deshalb fordern wir von bild deutschland
zusammen halten sich dieses land jetzt
auseinander droht uns ein terror der
korona leugner wie wollen und können wir
noch gemeinsam in die zukunft gehen dazu
jetzt hier bei uns im studio bild lei
chef claus strunz und er spricht ein
klartext kommentar klaus schönen guten
tag guten morgen wie sehr spielt chor
oder das hat unsere gesellschaft ich
glaube wir beobachten gerade eine echte
zerreißprobe für unsere demokratie ist
es mehr als ein stresstest und es wird
sich jetzt zeigen wie wir alle gemeinsam
darauf reagieren und das ist ja völlig
klar wer sich radikalisiert hast diese
demokratie zu unserer demokratie gehört
streitkultur zu unserer demokratie
gehören
meinungsaustausch da gehört auch debatte
und des chors da gehören argumente aber
was keinen platz hat ist der pressung
hetze und all das was wir jetzt vermehrt
auf unseren straßen und in den sozialen
medien er beobachten können das hat kein
platz da müssen wir alle einen akzent
setzen das wollen wir nicht aber wir
wollen natürlich über die probleme klar
sprechen und da auch kein blatt vor den
mund nehmen was sagst du diesem fackeln
ob dort in sachsen ganz persönlich also
30 offensichtlich fehlgeleitete leute
die sich gelinde gesagt im mittel ihrer
wahl beim protest vergriffen haben das
ist die wohlwollende deutung oder es
sind eben wirklich nach rechtsaußen
verrutschte verrückte die die ministerin
offen bedrohen wollten so ist es
jedenfalls wahrgenommen worden und bei
aktionen wie diesen kommt es nicht
darauf an was diejenigen
beabsichtigt haben dies getan haben
sondern was diejenigen empfinden die
darunter zu leiden hatten und vor dem
hintergrund ist völlig klar wie das zu
bewerten ist hat in deutschland keinen
platz und wer das macht hat auch kein
platz in dieser demokratie lasst uns
auch noch mal über die szenen hier aus
berlin sprechen in der u-bahn wo die
menschen so aneinander geraten sind
dagegen die wirklich durch das durch den
kopf und durchs herz zum ersten mal so
etwas wie hilfe hilfe was passiert da
gerade mit unserer gesellschaft was
passiert dass es so aufheizen kann die
menschen wären die da schreiben ist wird
mit dir gespritzt das ging die rechnung
also ich tue mir da ein bisschen schwer
das ist natürlich komplett abzulehnen
handgreiflichkeiten übergriffe
körperverletzungen leute irgendwo
rausdrängen überhaupt anzufassen und
sowas kann kein mittel des
demokratischen diskurses seien aber die
frage die mich umtreibt ist wer hat
eigentlich die verantwortung dafür dass
es so weit kommen kann wir können jetzt
nicht nur sagen die fackelzüge die
u-bahn drängler sind allein die bösen
die sind böse keine frage und haben in
der demokratie meiner auffassung nach
keinen wirklichen glanz verdienen wenn
wir demokraten müssen uns aber fragen
was in diesem land passiert ist dass das
möglich ist und das dreht sich wenn ich
das richtig sehe ja mehr oder weniger um
die frage einer allgemeinen impfpflicht
also aus den corona leugnern
indiskutable leute also kohle leugnen
ist vollkommen indiskutabel
vermischt sich jetzt eine gruppe mit
impfgegnern und impfgegner gibt es aber
mit gutem recht auch in der mitte der
gesellschaft mit guten argumenten ich
zum beispiel bin auch kein freund der
allgemeinen impfpflicht ich habe mich
zwar impfen lassen weil ich es für mich
für besser halte und für die die mit mir
zu tun haben aber einer pflicht da hätte
ich doch große fragezeichen und die
diskussion muss im parlamentarischen
raum ausgetragen werden und jetzt kommt
der punkt der mich besiegt im
parlamentarischen raum wird er nicht
mehr ausgetragen weil jetzt plötzlich
alle für eine allgemeine impfpflicht
sind wenn aber im parlament nur noch
radikale sind die das aussprechen was 20
prozent einer bevölkerung der mitte für
richtig halten dann trifft das land in
eine schwierige situation
das ist also ein dringender appell an
die abgeordneten von cdu csu und fdp von
grünen von fdp bei der freien abstimmung
die offensichtlich kommt über die frage
einer allgemeinen impfpflicht wirklich
nur ihrem gewissen zu folgen dass ein
gewisses test für jeden abgeordneten
eine gewissensprüfung und zwar kann ich
auch gleich das argument mit liefern das
mich jetzt schon dass mich jetzt schon
beängstigt es wird viele geben in der
mitte des parlaments sie werden sagen
ich habe kein gutes gefühl bei einer
impfpflicht das darf der staat nicht
aber dann stimme ab wie die afd und das
will ich auf gar keinen fall und dann
werden alle die zweifel haben womöglich
aus der afg bedrohung heraus eine
falsche entscheidung treffen die nicht
wie es gewissens war und dann ist das
parlament nicht mehr der repräsentant
der bürger sondern dann ist es eine
abstimmung maschinerie einer umgekippten
regierung einmal ganz konkret nochmal
auf dieser bahn situation dort am
wochenende hier in berlin das ging ja
erst mal davon aus dass dort so genannte
querdenker rhein sind in die bahn und
provoziert haben dadurch dass ihr alle
keine maske getragen haben jetzt kann
man das gut oder schlecht finden mit der
maske fliegt aber moment ist das halt
einfach an gesagt man soll die maske
tragen in der bahn wir kennen das hier
aus berlin aus anderen großstädten in
diesen alltagssituationen da sitzen dann
leute teilweise auch gruppen von leuten
provozieren ohne maske jetzt sitze ich
irgendwo in der nähe wie soll ich mich
verhalten ohne dass das nicht sofort
eskaliert also diesen klassischer fall
von zivilcourage und zivilcourage endet
glaube ich auch für den der sie ausübt
bei körperlichkeit aber der hinweis
darauf dass man sich wünschen würde und
ich würde es immer raten ganz persönlich
zu machen nicht hier gilt die regel
daran muss man sich halten du verstehst
dagegen sondern doch einfach den dialog
zu suchen und zu sagen ich fühle mich
jetzt hier nicht sicher könnten sie
nicht in eine maske aufsetzt das wäre
der beginn eines dialogs mein gefühl ist
dass dann die masken gegner er die
verrohrungen spiel bringen und dann
haben wir es eben mit radikalen zu tun
die wir in der gesellschaft nicht wollen
dass die masken pflicht und es beim
schwer zu kontrollieren sein wird war
denen in die wiege gelegt die sie
beschlossen haben und die müssen auch
dafür sorgen dass es solche szenen nicht
gibt